okay so mike's grabbing single handed
there are traditionally three ways we
practice this one is the low entry and
this low entry i'm going to push the
hand down while i cut on top clearing my
wrist
second is the mid that's the one i just
demonstrated i'm going to come right in
the middle i'm going to grab my wrist
isolating his hand push my elbow in
towards him and slide behind him
and the last entry is the high entry
where i drive the hand up like this you
can see i'm already starting to break
free but i also had this hand to make
better control and isolate his hand
better so i can either go high
mid
or low on this entry
a part of the big thing about eating
that's the real inaudible of this throw
is to get behind mike from this position
i'm going to grab mike's collar and pull
him off balance now if mike is ready to
fall right from here i can simply pull
him down but i don't quite get him so i
go ahead and bring this outside hand up
and step through driving him down
one more time to speak
out
thought